The challenges here are similar in
many respects to those around EHRs.
While efficiency may not
be quite as important,
usability is arguably even more
important and difficult to achieve.
Patients, including the elderly
who may not have support at home,
must be able to use these technologies.
The technologies are obviously capable
of generating vast amounts of data for
millions of patients.
No one has time to look at it all.
So analytic and visualization tools
that minimize false positives and
appropriately alert providers
are of critical importance.
This is an area where
machine learning and
other tools of artificial
intelligence are being applied.